- After a month of just
working with my dancers,
I looked at them, and I said,
"Whoa, they look like a real company."
And then I also said,
"Wow, Cambodia's first
gay dance company just
formed in my living room."
My name is Prumsodun Ok.
I am a Khmer classical
dancer and choreographer.
Khmer classical dance is an art form
that's more than 1,000 years old.
The art form has animist,
Hindu, Buddhist roots,
and it's all at once a
form of entertainment,
a form of worship, and also
a form of educating people.
In 1970s, in Cambodia,
the Khmer Rouge took over
the country, and they were a
group of radical Communists
who wanted to eliminate
all forms of elite culture.
Because of this, Khmer
classical dancers were targeted.
A third of the entire population died,
and in that number were
90% of Khmer dance artists.
So it was a real tragic loss
because Khmer classical dance
is not passed on in a book.
The act of reviving this art form,
of preserving this art form, is really
a protest against a legacy of violence,
and it's really a gesture of resilience
of beauty, a resilience
of the human spirit.
I was born and raised in
Long Beach, California,
which is home to the
largest Khmer diaspora
outside of Southeast Asia.
I realized that, if I wanted
to make the biggest impact
on the art form, I had
to do it from Cambodia.
So, in 2015, I started
Prumsodun Ok and Natyarasa,
which is Cambodia's
first gay dance company.
We have two primary missions.
One is to preserve the art form,
but also creating new work
that reflect our experiences
as LGBTQ people in Cambodia.
I felt like I really opened up a door
for many young men who have
always loved classical dance
but never had access to proper training.
These young men, all of a sudden,
had someone that they can
seek that knowledge from.
My friends are often
surprised when I say this,
but in certain ways, I feel that
Cambodia is much more tolerant and open
when it comes to LGBTQ
issues than other places.
There have been some people,
maybe they don't like gay
people or LGBTQ people,
but when they see the
rigor of the dancing,
the rigor of the costumes,
when they see the artistic quality,
they realize that it's coming
from a place of real love
and real respect and real devotion,
and they also see a sense
of hope for the future.
I hope that, in the future,
we take care of this art form
as beautifully as we
can, both traditionally,
but then, we also use this art form
to just create things that
would make our ancestors say,
"Wow, I never would've imagined that."